bonsoir je suis très impressionné parce
que j'ai pas l'habitude de faire court
je suis prof en fait j'ai pas l'habitude
de faire court devant autant de gens ces
cas là parce que effectivement des mes
élèves ils sont bien vivants n'est pas
que je ne suis pas pour cette noire mais
ils sont bien vivants et ils sont
spontanés spontanéité c'est peut-être ce
qui les caractérise le plus cette
spontanéité
je me souviens par exemple d'un dalle
élèves il ya quelques temps déjà acquis
dans un cours d'éducation civique qu'on
faisait sur la justice me dis enfin dit
à la glace en fait monsieur tout en
parlant d'un la terroriste islamiste
s'est dit ouais il est innocent il est
en prison il est innocent je termine
c'est intéressant ça tu as donc des
informations que la police justice n'ont
pas sera intéressant de tulle et le
partage
mais il ne dit pas de ça il dit oui il
est innocent et il est en prison
pourquoi vous le gardez vous saviez vous
c'est le prof c'est moi qui est ce vous
dans cet élève cette exclu puisque s'il
y avoue vous c'est vous et moi s'il y
avoue c'est qu'il y a eu faille à lui et
eux
quel est donc ce discours qui veut que
une partie de mes élèves de nos enfants
finalement de france eh bien ce ne se
sentent pas faire se noue sanaryens
nouveau tout cela moi ça fait 18 ans que
j'enseigne dans cette famille assad
lui-même dans un collège sensible du
prof d'histoire géo et d'éducation
civique leur est notée
et ça fait 18 ans que j'entends ce type
de discours alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
face à ce type de discours faste ce type
de ressenti parce que ce ressenti il est
important on doit le prendre en compte
on doit les entendre ses enfants ses
élèves j'allais dire mais ce sont des
enfants on doit les écouter
qu'est ce qu'on fait on fait à court
terme bien sûr on fait notre boulot de
prof dit voilà qu'est ce que tu veux
dire par là qu'est ce que qu'est ce que
tu entends parce vous qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que tu veux exprimer
on leur apprend à argumenter on leur
apprend à construire un discours logique
et structurée et puis on lui on essaie
de leur apprendre à penser en leur
donnant un enseignement de qualité enfin
qu'on veut de qualité mais on essaye
aussi de travailler à plus long terme de
les ouvrir les ouvrir au monde de les
ouvrir à des espaces à des territoires
qu'ils ne connaissent pas je ne
fréquente pas à des personnes à des
personnalités qui n'ont pas le même
capital social même capitale culturelle
qui viennent d'autres horizons
et pour cela rien de mieux que ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui la pédagogie de
projet monter des projets voilà on en
compte tous les ans des projets les
profs partout font un énorme travail
pour ouvrir ces gamins au monde pour
leur faire découvrir d'autres espaces
que le leur moi j'ai eu de la chance en
janvier 2015 j'ai rencontré laurence
bloch la directrice de france inter à sa
demande d'ailleurs et avec la
journaliste emmanuelle davier on a mis
au point un projet qu'on a appelée
interclasses peut-être que certains
d'entre vous connaissent là le projet
interclasses j'y croyais pas trop au
début et puis et puis finalement ça a
été une expérience extraordinaire
on a là je vous explique le but le but
c'est l'idée c'est que des élèves de
classes de milieu on va dire sensible
des territoires sensibles les produisent
une émission d'une heure pour france
inter émission diffusée dans la grille
d'été et
évidemment vous aimez ce n'est pas
évident et l'idée est de choisir un
thème de société
les élèves choisissent et qui décline
qui décline ce thème de société en
quatre zones à zoom pour ceux qui n'ont
pas la radio c'est un reportage de 4
minutes 30 à peu près donc il fallait
choisir un thème s'est réuni avec les
élèves ils ont beaucoup discuté en
l'état fin de nuit on sait qu'on va
avoir comme thème les jeunes la banlieue
la dureté on a eu l'amour je vais tomber
de ma chaise bon je m'y attendais pas du
tout je me suis dit voilà l'amour oui
pourquoi pas puis bon jeu peut-être
qu'ils en ont énormément à donner au
lapd être long à recevoir je sais pas
mais en tout cas ils ont choisi l'amour
que prison décliner ils ont décliné en
fonction de deux évidemment de leurs
préoccupations et des préoccupations
premières de 2 c de ces gamins de ces
petits gamins de france c'est celle des
réseaux sociaux ou alors voilà on va
faire un reportage sur les l'amour et
les réseaux sociaux
ok et puis un deuxième reportage qu'il a
aussi finalement semble logique parce
que parce que c'est quelque chose qui
les structures pour beaucoup d'entre eux
l'amour et la religion comment la
religion voit-elle l'amour et que la
religion permettait de faire en amour
par exemple troisième thème qu'il a un
peu plus un peu plus noir parce que il
renvoie il renvoie peut-être au
quotidien de certains c'est l'amour et
la prison comment voilà comment en
prison on vit l'amour on vit d'amour
avec ceux qui sont douar conçois qu'on
soit un homme ou une femme
voilà comment on vit l'amour en prison
et puis le dernier il m'a un peu surpris
c'était comment parce que l'amour c'est
le même à tout âge est ce que on se
représente l'amour à 80 ans comme on se
représente l'amour à 25 voilà sont des
questions qui leurs sont passées par la
tête et qui en disent ont finalement sur
le questionnement qu'ils ont sur eux
mêmes sur leur vie sur le retour
et ce qui est formidable dans ce dans ce
projet où des journalistes sont venus
sont venus travailler avec nous c'est
bien c'est l'ouverture que cela leur a
procurés l'ouverture que cela a donné
parce qu'on est sortie du collège on a
été faire du micro trottoir
on a fait de gros trous noirs un fan
lille donc c'était chez eux ce n'est pas
pareil on accorder quand même aller au
delà du périphérique
parce que c'est à dire qu'on est on est
rentré dans paris en fait mais vous
rigolez mais il ya un certain style
avait jamais mis les pieds à paris saint
denis d'ici 6 à 13 km c'est au bout de
la ligne 13 entre paris et deux bouts de
la ligne 13 il ya cinq stations cinq
stations cette aventure pour certains
donc on est sorti on est allé dans paris
peu de rencontrer des gens alors on a
rencontré des biens je sais pas comment
ça marche voilà ça c'est moi c'est
toujours moi
là c'est mon nom voilà et ça c'est le
titre que j'ai voulu donner à ce petit
voilà c'est vachement bien
donc je sais ce que je vais faire c'est
que j'ai le poser est donc je vais
continuer tant donc voilà on a on a
rencontré des gens on a rencontré par
exemple on a été dans une synagogue où
les élèves qui sont très majoritairement
musulman centrer pour la prévalence du
sida gogh
on a rencontré un rabbin c'est normal
dans une synagogue et le rabbin était
comme ça en fait mais les années où
j'étais hyper des contacts gens posaient
pas de questions il est resté trois
heures est arrivée en retard au collège
on sait enfin voilà mais voilà c'était
une rencontre hyper enrichissant
d'ailleurs le rabbin du coup il me
rappelle et où il veut continuer et on a
rencontré à l'imam on a rencontré un
prêtre dans son aumônerie on a rencontré
des la directrice de meetic france les
hyper impressionnant les élèves y aidera
la directrice de meetic france dans des
galas par akiva sur meetic quand même
nom mais bon en tout cas il connaissait
tous connaissaient tous mythique puis on
a vu ce qui se passe à l'autre côté des
voies là où s'est ouvert ils se sont
ouverts à d'autres
d'autres mondes on est allé à la prison
de villepinte dont le sas d'entrée
là c'était c'était très fort parce que
parce qu'on a rencontré des mamans on a
rencontré d'aider des jeunes femmes des
femmes un peu plus âgés qui emportait
qui apportait enfin qui venaient voir
leur leurs maris qui venaient voir leur
amoureux qui va voir leur fils et j'ai
en tête cette femme qui a porté toute
les semaines son linge à son fils et qui
le parfumé et la petite gamine qui
faisait l'interview qui faisait
l'interview qui faisaient ces questions
et qui en même temps pleurait c'était
très fort ce moment extrêmement fort
très émouvant
on est allé on a rencontré alors des
experts des sociologues des psychologues
on a rencontré un ancien détenu nous a
parlé de l'amour en prison on a
rencontré
les personnes âgées dans une maison de
retraite ça c'était assez formidable
parce que les élèves avaient préparé des
questions les questions un petit peu
dérangeante
est-ce qu'on se voit nulle à 80 ans
réfléchit css convenu à 85 alors les
plus gênés là dedans ce n'est pas du
tout les personnes âgées 1 qui répandait
avait déjà sur rozoy nu c'était mes
élèves
et voilà mais bon on a rencontré
d'autres générations
donc en fait on a on a bougé on s'est
ouvert on est on est allé rencontrer les
gens il est allé leur parler on est allé
leur poser des questions mais mes élèves
avaient parfois des yeux voilés les yeux
que peuvent avoir des gosses face à
quelque chose qu'ils ne connaissent pas
et qui devant lequel ils sont admiratifs
et puis on a vécu un moment assez
extraordinaire chrome et blanc avait un
petit peu un petit peu de bol en mars
2016 on est à france inter pour notre
projet interclasses et puis là on tombe
sur bernard cazeneuve
il était alors mise de l'intérieur a été
encore ce n'est pas encore ça ne savez
pas vous peut-être mais et dont l'a
invité dans d'autres établissements
alors on a invité 15 9 il n'est pas venu
et méme a rappelé enfin pas lui un jeu
ça faire quand même
mais ils nous ont rappelés et 11 mai
venez au ministère avait au ministère on
est allé au ministère on l'a visité tout
le ministère la cellule de crise avec la
grande table comme à la télé comme les
américains oui mais là c'est france est
un
c'est mon côté aussi on sait faire des
trucs des experts tout ça et puis on
puis bernard cazenave est venu nous voir
quarante cinq minutes nous a consacré 45
minutes comme une vraie conférence de
presse mais elle avait préparé des
questions
ils ont posé des questions pendant 45
minutes il a eu un mot tu es ma maman
m'a beaucoup touché et a beaucoup touché
les élèves lundi
ici c'est le mystère de l'intérieur
c'est votre ministère c'est c'est à vous
parce que vous êtes citoyen de la
république française c'est vous c'est à
vous ici comme à tout citoyen est par
ces mots là
le ministre a montré toute la
considération c'est ce que j'ai vécu
comme ça moi est compris comme ça toute
la considération qu'ils avaient pour eux
pour ces gamins parce que ces gamins qui
sont hyper dynamique spontanée vous avez
bien compris et bien ils ont énormément
de choses à nous dire énormément de
choses à nous apprendre énormément
d'énergie
il faut aller la chercher l'énergie faut
les écouter il faut les entendre il faut
il faut les considérer aussi bien dans
l'enseignement qu'on leur donne que dans
la proche qu'on a deux il faut faire en
sorte qu' il y ait plus heureux et nous
mais que tous ensemble nous fassions un
nous et donc il faut si je peux me
permettre de vous le vous dire là il
faut pas ce serait bien voilà tout
simplement que vous aviez les voir voilà
merci
[Applaudissements]